if you were having an operation you may
be given general anesthesia to put you
to sleep and keep you free from pain
your doctor may recommend general
anesthesia for a procedure that is
extensive takes a long time or requires
you to be in an uncomfortable position
before your procedure an IV line will be
placed in a vein in your arm using a
small tube called a cannula
the IV will deliver fluid and
medications directly into your
bloodstream you may receive some
medication to help you relax
you will be placed on the operating
table and made as comfortable as
possible a blood pressure cuff will be
placed on your arm to check your blood
pressure readings sticky pads will be
placed on your chest to check your heart
rate and a clip will be put on your
finger to check your body's oxygen
levels these devices allow the
anesthesia specialist to closely monitor
your vital signs before during and after
your procedure you will begin receiving
general anesthesia by either breathing
anesthetic gases through a mask or
through IV injection which will cause
you to fall asleep once you are asleep
you will be given a mixture of oxygen
and anaesthetic gases either through
your mask or through a special tube
inserted through your mouth and into
your windpipe
the tube is attached to a respirator
which helps you breathe while delivering
the gases to your lungs
deep in your lung tissues the gases are
absorbed into your bloodstream and
carried by blood cells to your brain the
anesthesia prevents your brain from
receiving messages from nerves in your
body as a result you will remain asleep
and pain free during your procedure and
you will have no memory of it when you
wake up after your operation the
anesthesia specialist will give you
medications to reverse the anesthesia
and you will awaken quickly if you had a
breathing tube in place he or she will
remove it as soon as you can safely
breathe on your own you will be taken to
the recovery room where you'll be
closely monitored and given pain
medication as needed
you may feel light-headed and slightly
disoriented but this feeling should pass
quickly once you are stable you will be
sent to a hospital room or home